charli's YouTube midlife crisis in the
morning I was hanging there the great
Hank green of vlogbrothers fame but
that's all you're gonna see them today
because he's going to the doctor which
means that I have full reign of Hank's
off this whew I'm really enjoying things
it's always so much fun to see a place
on the Internet and then see that place
in real life it's like I can reach out
and touch bits of the internet and or
move them around one thing that isn't so
amazing about this office though is
Hanks tripod hike you need to get a new
tripod please because this this is not
what a tripod should be doing this
listen to that squeaking apart from that
I am very excited to be here I feel like
I should have like a really good reason
as to why I'm here in Montana like a
super cool video project that I'm gonna
be working on with Hank but the truth is
that I just really like Hank and I don't
get to see her very often usually the
only FaceTime contact we get is like for
half an hour at VidCon and that happens
like once a year but I decided that
wasn't good enough and so here I am in
Montana with Hank green who's at the
doctor so that was worth it if you
follow me on Twitter then you probably
already know that getting here wasn't
quite as easy as I was hoping it would
be I was awake at about 4:00 in the
morning yesterday after about three
hours sleep so that I could get in
Heathrow in time for my 7 o'clock in the
morning flying and when I got to the
airport about 5:00 in the morning this
really fun thing happened where the
check-in people said that my ticket had
been cancelled and I said no I wanna
please I'm here to go and plane please
they've said no and I said but okay I'll
buy a new ticket then so I spent a lot
of money trying to get here to Montana
as you know I wanted to come here the
thing for me about having like airplane
troubles and stuff though is that I mean
generally for me I just don't enjoy
going on planes even when there aren't
my cancellation issues I just like hate
being on planes just kind of stuck in a
metal tube in the sky for hours and I
know it's sort of irrational but
whenever I'm given like airplane food I
just look at it and want to throw up
automatically but as much as I really
don't like going to places overseas I do
really really like being in places
overseas and so I'm happy to put up with
all of the uncomfortableness because I
know that eventually I'm gonna be doing
something
really cool like video blogging in Hank
Green's office you might recall that in
my youtube rules part 1 video I think
might have been part 2 I'm not sure one
of the rules that I mentioned was the
fact that I don't like to give the
people who watch me any kind of group
audience name I just like speaking
directly to you the person who's
watching this all wheezywaiter the guy I
mentioned in the video the guy who calls
his audience beardlovers he made a video
there it is you click on it if you want
about why he calls his audience bit
laughs I just think it's pretty good and
that you should watch it and it's also
just a great example about how different
youtubers can have different opinions
about how they think vlog you should
work but still coexist and have their
personal rules work for them so yeah go
watch that video i'ma go now cuz America
is really hot and that is making me
really hot and so gonna go cool down
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool